you're not able to let go of your
tightness when it comes to a woman
something's wrong with you man just let
go spend some extra money spend the
extra 10 quid that you might need to
spend on taking you to someplace
different but it signals a kind of
cheapness and it's not about money it's
about a cheapness in your spirit maybe
you don't have that much but my God you
have enough it's not gonna like make if
you're that poor then okay maybe but
probably not you could afford it show
that it means something to you seduction
is a language it's not a language of
words it's a language of gestures that
we're paying attention to we're paying
attention to people's body language
we're paying attention to their actions
to the things that they never say so
when you signal that discounts are so
important to you that even on the first
date you have to have a discount you're
signaling that it's something tight
about you in your nature and it's not
very pleasant